[Music]
so liz cheney's from northern virginia
but somehow she wound up as the only
member of congress from wyoming how'd
that happen well nepotism obviously but
what's interesting is that rather than
represent wyoming cheney decided she's
going to spend her time in congress
representing something called
democracy
watch
every one of us who has sworn the oath
must act to prevent the unraveling of
our democracy understand the peril of
this moment for our democracy as the
party of reagan republicans have
championed democracy democracy is
fragile
democracy is fragile democracy is
fragile democracy only survives if
citizens are willing to defend it
so it turns out democracy is like that
boyfriend you've got in another city you
kind of talk him up a lot but you don't
really want him to show up other people
to meet him what happened to liz cheney
last night democracy showed up in
wyoming and liz cheney suffered the
single biggest defeat in a primary by an
incumbent this century
so it turns out democracy is a cruel
master you got to be careful i can whip
around and bite you in the butt
but what's funny is that over at cnn
they're still defending democracy but
they have no idea what it is
from cnn's perspective and from liz
cheney's it turns out democracy means
you shut up
and submit to the rule of people who
haven't been elected in the case of liz
cheney cnn believes democracy means
keeping her in power despite the fact
that people she represents don't like
her watch this
we're keeping
a close watch on wyoming and what
happens there tonight could add to a
trend and that is election deniers
winning primaries around the nation what
does that mean for our democracy and the
risk of more chaos like what we saw on
january 6.
so
when voters
totally reject a candidate that we in
cnn like when voters actually vote which
is of course the
core ritual of democracy it's the
essence of democracy when they do that
it's a threat to democracy and of course
liz cheney agrees her losing
definitively in wyoming is the greatest
threat to democracy since the civil war
and she should know because effectively
she's abe lincoln
the great and original champion of our
party abraham lincoln was defeated in
elections for the senate and the house
before he won the most important
election of all
lincoln ultimately prevailed he saved
our union and he defined our obligation
as americans for all of history
i lost lincoln lost me me me me i'm
lincoln
another sad middle-aged rich lady
narcissism trip for sure
but you have to wonder if there aren't
lessons in all of this
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight